[Musique]
vous êtes en train de tester vos
connaissances
il est maintenant de la sixième ambiance
studieuse pour la rentrée de ses élèves
du collège de terre sainte
ici le travail semble bien lui dit je
peux vous déranger les jeunes non les
cours de maths et vous jouez
bonjour ma frange plus de livres on
appris de la main tendue sur tablette
1 c'est bien c'est moins lourd dans le
sac regardez le point remédiation le
numérique est au centre du
fonctionnement de la classe une nouvelle
façon d'apprendre
pour les élèves c'est un plus c'est
façon alors il ya un terme qui s'appelle
serious games donc bon moi j'adore ça
apporte cette dimension ludique en
mathématiques parfois sont un peu
austère certains et les applications à
l'heure actuelle donc vraiment été bien
que développée pour mettre l'élève en
confiance pour pouvoir se tromper
recommencer et progresser et simplement
et ce jour là le département livre à cet
établissement
les dernières tablettes d'un plan
numérique initié par l'état 53 collèges
sont équipées de symbolique tablette ce
qui correspond à un million deux cent
mille euros d'équipements c'est vrai que
les parents ne se doute pas de
l'investissement qui a réalisé par
département son niveau câblage donc on
niveau bâtiment mais aussi au niveau au
service avec
connexion internet et lançant des appels
d'offres qui seront lancés pour faire
les acquisitions d'équipements pour la
paix de la pédagogie au quotidien ce
volet là c'est le conseil départemental
qui vient accompagner les établissements
soit à travers des dotations qui sont en
faveur des collèges ou bien avec des
marchés qui sont directement porté par
le département pour faire des
acquisitions d'équipements une
compétence obligatoire du département
qui s'inscrit dans la dynamique
pédagogiques des collèges de l'île avec
souvent un référent numérique
incontournable nous avons des élèves qui
sont équipées de téléphone et on peut se
dire que ouais bah ils savent tous
utiliser le numérique rock c'est faux
lissa l'utiliser pour des loisirs pour
autre chose mais pas dans le cadre du
travail qu'il faut que les élèves soient
prennent plaisir à apprendre plein de
plaisir dans ce qu'ils sont en train de
fermer les enseignants aussi ce collège
classé aurait plus est en passe de
changer de statut avec ses bons
résultats au brevet obligatoire ou
volontariste le département accompagne
l'évolution des méthodes pédagogiques de
notre jeunesse
[Musique]